بعد ان قامت الحكومه التوصيليه بتخفيف
القيود الخاصه بفيروس كورونا وقال العديد
من كبار السن فريسه للفيروز ما يشكل ضغوط
كبيره على العاملين في المستشفيات في
مستشفى الشعبي غرفه الطوارئ
مستويات الاكسجين في الدم
من كبار السن ويعانون من حالات مرضيه
مزمنه اخرى ضغط الدم والسكري وامراض القلب
والسمنه
يجب ارسال المريض الى المستشفى اذا كان
يعاني من نقص الاكسجين في الدم واعراض
اخرى هناك عوامل انذار مبكر للمرضى
المسنين تشير الى حاجتهم الى الرعايه
الطبيه
وقامت المستشفيات في المدن الصينيه
المختلفه بتكثيف جهودها لعلاج ذوي الحالات
الحرجه المصابين بفيروس كورونا حيث ان عدد
حالات الاصابه بالفيروس اخذ في الارتفاع
هنا في مستشفى بكين الشعبي مثلا تم تخصيصه
خط ساخن لاستقبال مكالمات المرضى على مدار
اربعين 24 ساعه اما في مقاطعه هوباي في
وسط الصين تم اضافه اسره جديده لاستقبال
الحالات الحرجه المصابه بالفيروس ووافقا
لسلطات الصحيه الحكوميه فاقعد عدد
الاصابات اليوميه بفيروس كورونا مليون
حاله في مدينه تشنج يونج
عدد الاصابات في البلاد 37 مليون حاله
يوميا